foreign
welcome to the show a uh question of the
day is
what is something in the past that you
really really wanted or needed but you
couldn't afford it
um oh my like an item it could be an
item it could be a service it could be
uh
um a medical procedure like anything
that you just any time that you ran into
that moment where you're like [__]
it's not feasible yeah ear reduction you
know the Lego still can't you guys
remember the the Legos pirate series yes
yeah
the pirate ship bro the big one well how
much was it back then like 130 It Was
Out Of Reach man my dad was like yo that
is you have expensive taste and he goes
but I'll do something similar you can
get the smaller you know there was a
smaller one yeah the Schooner yeah you
got a scooter [__] yeah I was like all
right cool and then like I was able to
save up and I got the the other you know
how those the Pirates and then there was
the castle
the good guys oh like the different
color Pirates no there was the pirate's
side and then there was the the guys
that were like the Royal Army oh with
the Blue Hats like a royal Navy yeah
those were the bad guys to me right the
Pirates were the good guys to me right
and then so that I got that so they
could battle okay but then I never saved
up enough myself to get the pirate ship
and it just felt like so the fight was
uneven yeah where my dad said it was too
expensive my head was already
unattainable ah yeah and then now I want
to go back on eBay and buy it and it's
like thousands of dollars
it's truly unattainable you know what it
was the sidekick oh the side that was so
cool
yeah that was cool remember the guys had
the holders and they pull it out yeah
bro did your homies have Sidekicks all
the homies had Sidekicks what were you
rocking at the same time the dance like
uh I think first the razor I had the
razor the razor that was cool yeah it
wasn't a sidekick no no yeah I am yeah
and I had like other cool phones that
did have like am but it still wasn't the
sidekick because you had T9 dude yeah
yeah yeah just seeing people go oh oh
that was the best yeah that's feeling
too like it was something about the
momentum with it oh yeah do you remember
how much it cost at the time because I
don't even remember what no but you had
to have T-Mobile first off right yeah
and a lot of cats would literally drop
their servers just to go to T-Mobile to
get the psychic my parents were like
[__] no what the [__] we're on a family
plan yeah exactly there's no way that
was the standard too before like because
what was it at the time it was sidekick
Blackberry I got the Blackberry a little
late but I got one when that was the
thing those were pretty cool yeah
Blackberry was cool dude says it was 249
back then which isn't anything compared
to what an iPhone is now the back then
that was a [__] now every iPhone 50
bucks yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's wild the sidekick LX type
that in was that the black one that was
like the sexy one yeah yeah the slim one
right yeah yeah LX let me see oh is it
this one is it yeah bro the LX I totally
go back and get one uh did you get one
now I feel like I might have got one
late because I had this thing there's
this place called Airtech in the mall
where I grew up and Airtech used to sell
like used phones and you could just get
in like put a SIM card in them and I
would go there like nice a year after
the phone like wasn't as cool anymore
and if I want to use and use my DJ money
to buy one so I think I have them for a
short period of time I think it might
have been the LX actually that is nice I
had the Blackberry yeah see this one was
sexy had the rollerball yeah that's
pretty nice
oh that's a Cadillac and you can play
games on it oh bro you got everything on
it I had that one I didn't know that
actually oh I totally forgot about this
circular like yeah anything like it was
a game the rollerball
it would light up different colors yeah
that's how you let a company die how the
[__] who the [__] makes sidekick how the
[__] are y'all not still a thing yeah
yeah come back to my guy come back I
know damn and we had so much allegiance
to that too like everybody loved oh
they're the best dude the fact that
people were just aiming in class I just
wasn't yeah you know what I wish I had
when I was little that I never got was a
tree house
oh really good yeah the science about it
because in my yard we would have like a
bunch of trees what kid didn't want that
yeah like damn I wish I had a [__]
house so you already had the tree in
place too yeah it was all there the tree
house was like a kid's like [__]
thing it's a dream man about having that
and just like going up there [__]
like doing whatever yeah same I did too
we never had that I think I used to lie
and say it
[Laughter]
if I ever have a son I feel like I would
never build him a tree house just
because like what else could he want
after that point oh you might peek the
kids who had tree houses like they
wanted for nothing yeah and they've
never used it no no they never use their
[__] tree you know why it's because
of [__] movies dude movies yeah
the tree house yeah the Hey Arnold room
is the best room that was the [__]
but when they had like a tree house or a
clubhouse it was always like your
parents love you yeah yeah you did your
parents are doing pretty good companies
how to build tree houses like just
reality what what they're dope damn are
they made mainly for the dats
yeah it's like for their dreams yeah now
you need to have Wi-Fi in there dude
cable don't do Wi-Fi you you force them
to like just play with like analog stuff
inside so they have to kind of like get
away from technology in the treehouse
that's nice yeah a big way for them to
never use the treehouse
great way to turn them off from it give
me a storage closet for them one thing
that I I really remember doing I was
like 18 19 and I used to walk into Urban
Outfitters all the time and not be able
to buy one thing and I would spend so
much time just looking at everything oh
yeah that was back when Urban was kind
of new and like kind of fresh like
during metrosexual era yeah good ERA I
wanted that look so bad and I was just
stared everything and look at tags and
go oh
it's so
I'm like they must have noticed by now
that I'm the same dude going in there
just going
screaming upstairs yeah so it was like
it was a sad thing man I just remembered
like I would just imagine I would try on
clothes and go Sunday I look in the
mirror and go Sunday but not today
remember when I was in high school I
found out about
um Crossroads and um yeah
right and um I wanted to take this girl
out who later became my long-term
girlfriend and I had no money even
though I had like jobs here and there I
just had him at this point so I went
into my closet and I literally cleared
out half my closet
um took it to Buffalo Exchange and took
all money I had and took the rest of the
clothes I didn't take the crossroads and
like gave away I mean I sold almost all
these clothes I had and got like 200
bucks because it's been on our first day
wow after that but I always found a way
to hustle so we probably wanted clothes
and because we're like oh go sell some
other [__] off yeah yeah yeah nice move
keep it moving oh you know what was a
big thing for me that was like one day
when I can pay for this on my own I'm
gonna get it it was cable TV
and it may be a black box or something
because every time I went to my friends
houses that had like Nickelodeon all
that blurred boobs I was like this is
the best yeah I was like what the [__]
how come we don't get cable and my dad's
like we don't need it it's free TV you
just move the Asian response
14 channels why do you need 200 what are
you gonna do do your homework and I was
like
I was so jealous of the kids they were
talking about Nickelodeon and all that
and then they're talking about Rugrats
and I'm like pretending that I hated
that feeling man I know are you being
left out yeah we watched two episodes
and you just try to remember every
character and everything so when they
talk you could [__] about episodes
that that's how we felt about X-Men the
cartoon because that came on on Saturday
it'll be Saturday and we couldn't watch
TV on Saturday because Seventh Amendment
so they'd be like you see X-Men the
cartoon I'm like you guys are lying I
went on this live I see that she doesn't
exist you know what I used to do because
I got cable pretty late and so I never
got to watch all the shows I went out
but I had a computer and I could see
like what shows were on like what
network like Cartoon Network Nickelodeon
whatever so I would go to like Walmart
or something buy the DVD and then watch
that
I like the whole cable thing oh it was
too expensive back then yeah it was like
what 80 90 bucks or almost like 100 for
like the whole thing DirecTV or whatever
yeah I remember joining band and in
fifth grade
and then I think most dudes I think
Mozart most dudes wanted to play the
saxophone it just looks cool yeah and
then I remember I don't want to play
saxophone and then uh
no no it was in the trumpet yeah
saxophone's pretty cool yeah everybody
wanted it by the side yeah no yeah it
was really cool so I remember going to
the music store with my mom who was like
recently divorced at the time and she
was complaining about price and stuff
all the time oh I'm gonna play that one
and then she go how much is that I think
it was like eight or nine hundred bucks
at the time yo that's a expensive size
yeah so she was like oh they're like oh
it's like 800 I could see my mom go 800.
oh [__] I don't want to play that that's
not what I want to play uh oh
it's like go down yeah and then I went
down to like
how much is that it was like a drum pad
you're like oh it's like 50 like that's
what I always wanted to play
you're a good kid practice
I thought it really it's not even the
actual snare drum it's just the practice
that's that's what I always watch I want
to play that one oh okay
your sweet for working with her though
sweet sweet boy and I would see the
dudes like it just Saxon away
[Laughter]
he's like nobody wants to play saxophone
anyway shoves them yeah yeah see how
much [__] you like learn like just
becomes a pattern from like not being
able to force it as a kid yeah it
becomes like who you like you know how
you just do things you don't see any
other way yeah that's true yeah he's got
into drums and then my Yamaha drum set
is like 3 500 later
too that's what we did because we
couldn't afford it either but my mom was
like we'll rent it and then if you are
not good at it we can just give it back
oh yeah no we didn't win we rented the
trumpet that I played it played a lot of
different things nice little burpees
from it
child herpes sucks bro
everyone's sharing it I was making out I
was making it I was totally kissing so
many girls what's something that you
couldn't afford okay so check this out
all right my favorite thing because I
grew up with uh mostly women in my
household right so every time they would
always go to the mall yeah and they'd
always shop and I would have nothing to
do so what store would I like to go to I
go into the Brookstone store oh
Brookstone
okay when I would I would just you know
I'm a young lad right and I would look
at and in my head I'd always say this I
was like man if I ever become a
millionaire like this is livid like this
is
like the way Mike Tyson has Tigers like
this is my tiger right the Brookstone
Store the Brookstone massage chair oh
yeah the calf massager dog yeah bro the
one that you put your whole foot in yeah
and then you just sit in there and then
your arms and then they're heated I
would just sit in there and I'd be like
man this is lit and you're a child doing
I'm a child
I do the same thing that was my first
stop at the mall that's it yes you just
touch everything in there before you see
girls you go to the birthstone you sit
there and you hit the whole thing yeah
I'm ready to go they would have personal
massagers which are like I think are for
masturbation honestly
yeah and I'm like this is I've seen
these in internet movies okay but
when I when I get in the chair I would
like anything like that it was like okay
that's what I want but you look at the
price tag and it's like oh yeah three
thousand dollars there man I was like I
can't even imagine anybody yeah and I
was like I was like I'm never gonna get
this I have to wait until like I'm 50 or
60 to buy one
and I'm like so that's that's my level
of living dude or like any kind of big
giant beanbag chair oh like love songs
bro I'll go on Amazon and I'll just like
I'll get ads on my my Instagram of like
these Moon pods have you seen those
they're like these giant like bean bag
chairs and I was like I don't know why I
have such a thing about them beanbag
chairs I want to be comfy I want to
become I just want to sit in it and I
Justified my head was like oh I could
like do work in there I was like you're
not good
no they're actually like 300 bucks oh
big beanbag chair giant bean bag chair
but I'm like we have nowhere to put it
is the problem we had a love sack at uh
David actually bought it for us oh yeah
for a housewarming gift uh way back in
the day and it's huge it's like as big
as this table
and uh one of my dogs got on top of it
peed pissed so it just soaked the whole
thing
it's like we live kind of on a hill like
this yeah so I'm like [__] it now it's
all Heavy you gotta pull it out and I
don't even know how to like how to throw
it away yeah so I was just at the top of
our house and I just pushed it down the
hill
all the way down to the street and now I
have a giant silk piss-filled bean bag
that's like literally like seven by
seven just it's nasty dude no that
happened to me too because I bought a
huge like a six foot bean bag and when
we were at the Whittier house and we had
two huge dogs the the German shepherd
and a husky they both peed on it they
both went into my room when I wasn't
there and then they just like lift their
leg pee on there and then I I would see
it I'm like do I need to give this [__]
away or something I need to like you
need to give away
they're expensive because I had like I
had two of those I had one that was like
it was like a thousand bucks all
together and then I lent it to Dietrich
for a video and then he kept it in his
house for a long time and then his dog's
pissed on it he [__] on it a few times
I was like yeah let's just throw it away
he bought me another one though I'm
never getting a [__] love set this
terrible last Horror Story yeah it's a
bad investment yeah they look cool in
the store they feel cool I like
something but we had I had a small one
that I bought for our house and it was
like it was a it was pretty sweet it was
pretty I don't want to brag but it was
pretty sweet but we had to throw it all
out right because someone ripped it one
of my friends sat in it and ripped yeah
and then beads just kept coming out
these like like foam beads oh yeah yeah
the exactly good because they're not
beads bro the anxiety of trying to throw
this all out it took me like four weeks
to be able to throw it out in batches in
my tracks it was such a pain in the ass
to get rid of so that's why I'm like I
don't even want a [__] bean bag chair
because if something rips for me to get
rid of it it's just foam LoveSac they're
foam blocks that you break up so it will
never do that I feel like my dogs are
gonna pee on me I still want a massage
chair though yeah
but the only thing is it's hard to make
a massage chair look good you got to put
it in your office any place you put in
the house if you have any room that's
slightly themed or designed it just
throws it off it's like [__] yeah it
looks like oh cool old Asian man lives
here
it looks so horrendous you know the
reality garages yeah
[Laughter]
oh my God the case while I went to they
had a massage chair room uh it was a
common land Salt Room soil room massage
chair room that's I think it was heated
and just go in there wow I think if you
have a massage chair in your house you
just have a tea set or something like
this so it makes sense yeah yeah you
gotta build out your room yeah karaoke
room so yeah it's so wow it's like a
grandpa room you theme it in that way so
it's like oh it's part of the design
yeah this is Zen room too yeah
and I also heard that sometimes those
things like there's a malfunction you'd
have like a repair guy yeah and that guy
costs a lot of money too oh I feel like
it's all a scam I think
I feel good is there anything you guys
are like uh I want to get now that's
like a little bit more expensive than
what you could afford but you're like as
soon as I can I'm gonna get this now or
soon happiness
thank you
uh I don't know I want um
like like a big garage space that I can
have all my auto toys in yeah and it's
like I could get more it's like a
workshop kind of right yeah and I want
to Workshop area that I can yeah
Workshop would be nice yeah because I
think um
it's like I need to I want I have ideas
of what I want
I have ideas of what I want I was gonna
go
[__] you
[Laughter]
thanks for sharing
yeah there's like but then the space and
where I'm Gonna Keep it is a big word
like I don't have any space yeah where
would you have like in Hawaii or Vegas
or here I'll have a Vegas storage space
for um because Vegas is my hub for road
trips like to Utah and Arizona and stuff
like that so I would like uh to finish
out my truck and then I would like get a
um like a a like an adventure bike or
something and in Hawaii yeah I'd get
um a Land Cruiser shipped over from
Japan I have my truck there I'm
finishing that project up and then I
just need space so I could bring stuff
up yeah like a hanger basically pretty
much yeah yeah like a little hand like a
like a kayak and all that and I'm
starting to think about maybe I'll take
um flight lessons in Hawaii too
yeah you might need two hangers yeah you
should just play Grand Theft Auto yeah
just get Shark cards
you'll be good I would love more counter
space in my kitchen dude I would love it
how do you think I need to get to I need
I think I need to move on more kitchen
um but yeah I would love more counter
space I was thinking about buying a kit
this is great YouTube content by the way
I was thinking about getting one of
those those make your own kitchen uh
like those islands and I was like I
think I'm just gonna do that yeah
and have I have more cabinet space yeah
more storage you know do you have the
space why are you rolling your eyes dude
do you have the space in your kitchen
for that I have good cabinets yeah I do
I do okay I could have a little spot we
have a little Nook yeah we have a little
kitchen no big deal I want Rags we all
got to save money for the deck when
these robots come out that's what we're
going to want like customized
[__] oh that'll be cool or something
yeah I'm gonna tell your robot build me
a [__] hanger
I can't wait till we get AI like
vehicles or like I could imagine like
surfboards that
are just attached to your feet like
snowboards and then you just roll like I
don't know like it's not gonna be like a
long learning curve but just you could
get right on and start doing crazy [__]
don't they have one that kind of looks
like that where it looks like this and
there's a thing here oh that's crazy
yeah and it just zooms yeah I want to
try that one yeah yeah there's that
thing where like you're on a [__]
it's connected too and you're like the
jet pack one yeah yeah
I want to do those I've seen people go
like 10 feet in the air and then they
fall oh my God they just end up
underwater yeah
[Music]